What is it like three inches or something? So it's like this this much. I was close really close butler has no time outs
Three its hey, we're pulling it down
To getting around so that one watches the shot
[is] the King of the dance?
Butler in this position for the first time ever taking on mighty duke whose dream will come true tonight
I asked our guys at the practice three days before
I said hey, there's a large contingent of people that have asked me
are you interested in measuring the Rims and measuring the free throw Line like the movie Hoosiers and
Our guys said hell, [no] people
[said] it was a cinderella story, and in our eyes. We didn't picture it like that at all
Butler was as good as any team in the country. They were physical they were confident. They were aggressive
[we] came into the national title game expecting to win that year you had this
unbelievably mature team who had been through the wars
Together we were at our highest [level] of play the entire season
We walked in to that national championship game with a lot of swagger
It was everything you wouldn't want a championship game to be how could you not like to watch that?
it felt like it was going to be a game that came down to the last possession pretty much throughout the
Second half you expect to get to that point where five four minutes are left in the game
And you start to pull ahead it was a game. We should have worn by eight ten points
the game kind of goes back and Forth
[we] cut a [five-point] lead 2-1 building up to a last shot opportunity 15 seconds
Mat-Su back to flexing
Stays with bunker with thirteen point six seconds [bunder] had the ball with an opportunity to take the lead
On an inbounds play with about 13 seconds left on the clock, okay [here] we go
Angle Detail has to call the timeout as a coach you never want to use your final timeout until you know
It's the very last possession
Butler has no timeouts. It's going to be howard instead of heyward
Well gives heyward a chance to be involved and maybe
Screening and catching the past well there it is out to heyward cut it right here
And I was told just to make a play I like going left more than anything
So I tried to go this way same worth defending [ten] seconds ago
He wants to drive and coming up, and I went behind the back and drove behind the back the whole time
I knew I'm gonna shoot this and zubik pops out right here
I was able to use my height all 72 of me and actually affect the play in a positive way on
[the] baseline makes [me] step back, but I arc it a little bit more than I normally would
three point six seconds
You know I missed it
That walk back to the other free-throw line [was] one of the longest walks. I've ever experienced now sit back put the line
to a couple dribbles
Made the first one
About the shoot the second one and briefly look over and let's get the signal to miss it
says missing
Coach K
Elected to have him miss the second one to not give butler a chance to run a set plate
It is [a] risk right because then it stays a two-point game
Missing that free-throw though does put a lot of pressure on you to get the ball up [the] court quickly
[you] don't win something big without taking some risk. You just don't want it to be Gamble's I
Didn't [gamble] I [wrist]
heyward had already made a game-winner in [this] state high school championship [game] and
Had already proven to be an outstanding clutch player
In [this] situation, let's see what they got lined up here. You know we're down
[12.1] seconds left and
You know we have to go the length of the court. I like to get the ball thingy work somehow
Honestly, I was definitely back of my mind this very similar situation
With the chance to win national title game in Indianapolis. I can definitely remember thinking here. We go again
Let's do it again that young man right there at a milan moment
Do you believe in sequels certainly looks that way better partner my goodness?
We've always put Gordon in a position that he would be our most likely to rebound
So you knew that our best player was going to get the ball again?
he misses the free throw and
From then it's playing off natural instincts the tape were pulling it down [did] I get the ball right here
And he kind of falls into me
I bodied him up for about a second to a second off the clock getting around [shoot] [back]
I end up dribbling it out this way. This is singular and he kind of steps up and picks me up
Matt howard comes in and sets a big time screen from right here
It allows me to kind of get [around] him
And end up shooting the shot right around here. It's like
When you're a kid, and you're in a gym, and you're counting down
You're like three two one and you just throw up the ball and try to try to make the shot
I'm gonna try. [it's] a word pulling it down getting it round so that at Midcourt
It's the king of the dance
It really did feel good on my hands off my fingertips from our angle that ball looked like it was going in
if it goes in I'm gonna be killed
It was pretty damn close
And it was right there [I]?
Missed the shot. So that's what happened. [I]
Can remember immediately thinking about the shot before the half court heave and thinking and that was the shot
[I] wish I could have that one back
Ironically last year when we're playing the jazz he hits the shot the exact same shot
Hey, we defended by Bradley Heywood gets a little daylight. [Haywood] a jumper nails at
1.7 on the clock
And literally came in my office right after the game and so that's a shot I've missed against Duke
[I] told him I'd rather hit the one in the championship instead of that one so [we] had a good laugh about that
But yeah, that's the shot that
I hit all the time you know our best player had the ball and everybody you know can live with that result
If it goes in and it'll go down as the greatest shot in the history of basketball the shot goes in
You know and you're asking me where [butler] would rank in terms of all-time underdog teams
Everybody else has to [be] the judge of that because to us we were supposed to win